[Music]
boy Kardashian's daughter has arrived
but so did turmoil lots of it
thanks to the baby's daddy Tristan
Thompson who was at the hospital even
though he's accused of cheating on chloe
with three different women while she was
pregnant
Tristan's cheating scandal was
definitely not in Chloe's birth plan in
the midst of being crushed and
devastated by the situation a ray of
light
their daughter arrived around 4 a.m.
this morning inside Cleveland's
Hillcrest hospital this is Tristan
outside the hospital this afternoon a
source tells ET he was quote lucky to be
there under the circumstances et has
also learned Chris
Kim and Courtney were inside the
delivery room isn't that scary we're
going to a whole other state have a baby
anyways don't all have to come that's
like me of course we will the baby does
not have a name yet and our source says
quote despite everything else going on
this is an incredibly happy day
I am so over-the-moon we love Tristan so
much and she's so happy and she's been
through so much Chloe hasn't ruled out a
happily ever after with Tristan but
their future is uncertain our source
says that he is apologetic and begging
for forgiveness but Chloe has decided to
fly home to Los Angeles to be with
family as soon as their daughter is
cleared for travel Topsail aims a trophy
last night at the Cleveland Cavaliers
final home game of the season fans gave
Tristan a chilly reception an eye
witness tells ET fans could be heard
booing when he came up on the jumbotron
this spectator held up by we heart Chloe
summer our source says Chloe wants to
believe Tristan has done nothing wrong
however a source who knows Tristan well
tells us quote anyone who believes
Tristan is an innocent guy who doesn't
cheat isn't being honest with themselves
what a mess and you wish Chloe and Matt
baby the best of me well we have been
told by a source that they are filming
keeping up with crashes right now
[Music]